started this project of digital
marketing sales automation
uh data management data consumption all
so that we can have a level of
transparency over what we're doing and
that we can trust in the data and the
numbers and what we're looking at
and anyone who could approach these
people and increase their trust i think
has a strong case to be able to sell a
product and i think that's what czech is
doing we ultimately
above everything else we're selling
trust
welcome to 20
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about go-to-market
strategy with security two
very very
exponentially growing fields in the last
decade and
now they're combining because now we
have
fake bots and fake users that are acting
as leads and obviously that's hindering
both cost of acquisition and it's
hindering the customer experience and
the ability for companies to actually
provide value and to optimize their
funnel to meet the right customers at
the right time with the right messaging
meet daniel avital the chief strategy
officer and global head of marketing for
czech
daniel is the chief strategy officer and
global head of marketing at czech the
leader in go-to-market security his role
spends across company positioning market
and category building brand and product
marketing communication and demand
generation
prior to check daniel served as the
senior director of strategy at gray
where he held brandon marketing strategy
for leading global brands including png
fiat group gsk and others
we all are doing in one way or another
customer acquisition you know whether
you're in tech or you're not in tech
especially in tech you're thinking about
the scale and and and the efficiency of
it but but then you're dealing with this
another problem that is very very
different but is integrating into it
which is you know bots fake
and fraud which is obviously with
digitalization it's exponentially more
than we had before and you're combining
two worlds that are so dominant today
and so i'm excited to talk to you about
as chief strategy of check
you know a little bit about what you
guys are doing and how you're thinking
through a lot of these problems so
daniel thank you so much for joining me
today
well thank you for again for having me
in for the uh generous introduction
um i think you hit nail on the head this
is a curious
company among other reasons because of
the intersection of
i guess you would call the world of
go-to market right so marketing user
acquisition sales data and analytics all
these sort of business
facing units
and with cyber security these are two
rules which usually
are siloed away and the cyber security
industry traditionally
has uh
no matter what solution you're
putting out in cyber security you have
one thing in common is that you are
selling to a security team to a chief
information
security officer and that the
applications you are selling as a cyber
security company
are meant
to reduce
risk and to secure and what do i mean by
that i mean that if you're on amazon.com
we're gonna protect your
customers credit card information if
you're mount sinai health we're gonna
ensure that your health records aren't
stolen if you're a nuclear power plant
we're gonna make sure north korean
hackers don't crash your critical
infrastructure this is what has
traditionally been thought as the main
application
of cyber security and will all of a
sudden comes along this
company check and says yeah you know
the internet's a bad place and it's the
wild west and 40 of the traffic out
there is bots and automation tools and
hackers and fraudsters and yes this is
all a security problem but it is also a
business problem it is also a business
for anyone in the go to market operation
anyone doing user acquisition or paid
marketing they're going to engage in
your funnels bots are going to fill your
audiences and you're going to remarket
to them or they're going to click on
your ads if you're operating a website
or e-commerce
they're gonna flood your website fill
out
forms they're gonna find themselves in
your crm so maybe your
sales team or your bdrs are now chasing
invalid leads which are going to waste
their time they're going to engage with
your chat worst of all
strategically they're going to
skew the data in your bi and analytic
systems right you're trying to force
first and project your business on bad
date
right and so just to understand the
magnitude of the problem
how how how dominant is this in today's
customer acquisition funnels and
everything that you just mentioned well
how how big is this
well i'll give you uh i'll give you a
data point be it which is real you know
companies put a data out there and i
heard uh
impervio say 50 52
of traffic today is bought i've heard
people say higher numbers than that i'll
give you a real data point from over 12
000 check customers that we service
today when
your check customer first plugs in
check and as we call it switches on the
light and sees the the fake traffic in
their funnels
we see an average of 27 of all direct
and organic website traffic to be
invalid in some way shape or form like
we said bots organization tools click
farms malicious users proxies you name
it 27 it's almost a third of all traffic
is not real
unbelievable okay and you're seeing this
and obviously just to ex you know to
elaborate on the problem because a lot
of people may look at this and say okay
great so you have so okay so you're just
losing a third of yours of your ad money
right but it's not that your your your
whole operation like you mentioned on
optimizing your lead generation and
understanding okay where is this user in
the funnel and what's making them drop
you're skewing the whole understanding
of the user behavior and not allowing
companies to internally adopt and adapt
and then you have dozens or hundreds of
engineers that are working on optimizing
lead flows for bots instead of for
actual people and actually delivering
value to the people who need it and who
can actually enjoy the product right so
this is a much deeper problem than just
spending more money on ads and and
raising your cac
i think so um
this
as you characterize it is not a tactical
problem of optimizing my marketing cap
right this is not what we're talking
about that is a that that is part of it
this is a deep strategic problem
uh this fake traffic it poisons
everything
it poisons your data it poises the
audience segments in your
cdp your advertising audiences your crm
your lead flows your conversion funnels
um it is a contamination
if i could borrow a
term
um
and uh i think the market is now
starting to realize that we're living in
this era the fake web and
you have to address that and when you
put together your strategic plans you
have a go-to market motion
and you have a marketing plan and you
have a sales plan and you have a
plan to protect yourself you know from
the fake web i think that's becoming
part of the culture too
so check what how do you actually go
about solving this we understand the
problem
huge important what what is there to do
how do you combine cyber security with
with with lead generation with marketing
yeah well you know the first challenge
is how do you
not just sell cyber security to a cmo or
a vp of i mean
yeah cso persona but how do you before
that how do you build a product for that
yeah right um i mean you take your
average bot mitigation waff
whatever it is and you put it in front
of i look i'm a market you put it in
front of me and i'm you know i
i might not find myself too easily
uh i think what we done very well at
check
is build that security product from the
go to market with the go to marketers
lens okay when you look at that
uh
dashboard it's speaking
the language that you're used to leads
clicks campaign sources
traffic sources affiliate marketers in
my network it's showing you metrics that
you care about it's showing you
information and reporting that you care
about and it's baked into your ecosystem
so it integrates with your analytics
or bi tools
it
matches up and integrates with your
audience with your advertising audiences
it works in all the environments so i
think that was really the big challenge
was
building that and of course there's the
technological challenge of accuracy you
know when you're a cso not to speak for
all of my cso friends
um but in a sense you're being swarmed
by adidas attack a full-scale
invasion to borrow another you know a
contemporary term and at that point you
you know you're firing will
as they say and you've got to stop
all the attack even if that means
there's some collateral damage that's
not the mindset of a
go-to market leader of a marketing team
right surgical precision the god forbid
we should accidentally block a real
paying customer that's dannon's for sure
there goes so there's
a certain level of nuance and
sophistication
in the technology um and accuracy built
in to make sure we're you know we're
zero percent false positives i think
it's an interesting challenge right
how do you evolve over time if you're
looking back at check and you're you're
looking at the way that you know both
your own understanding and the company's
understanding of of this world right and
and you've been around for some time you
know 12 000 customers incredible
how what what are you what do you learn
about the world working with so many
customers and developing this product
and owning this domain becoming a market
leader there
you know i guess
people
ultimately want
one thing especially when it comes to
the digital world increasingly digital
world in which we're living and it's
transparency and trust i think that's my
greatest
a
queen job my greatest understanding my
greatest insight for for working with
all these different people from
different industries from different
verticals i mean 12 000 customers that
covers a lot we have cyber security
customers we have bank and customers we
have retail we have health and education
and the list goes on it's all ultimately
about one thing we
started this project of digital
marketing sales
automation uh data management data
consumption all so that we can have a
level of transparency over what we're
doing and that we can trust in the data
and the numbers and what we're looking
at
and
anyone who could approach these people
and increase their trust
i think has a strong case to be able to
sell a product and i think that's what
check is doing we ultimately
above everything else we're selling
trust
right
right and and how does it actually work
with the with the customers so the
people that are actually using check
within the organization what what is
what is the product and the the
interface that they're experiencing to
to experience that and to give that
to others i think first of all there is
transparency baked in into our platform
there's a dashboard that pretty much
shows you at a high level everything
there's the ability to download log
level
uh reports
and to give you that more granular data
this ability to plug that into your own
bi environment via connector or via a
push api
so there's all these uh
options and that's literally half of
what the product does beyond the
blocking
gauging capabilities is that
transparency is that layer of visibility
that's how our customers
view us they always say you know we
put in check and
we switch the lights
other than that we know there's ways to
communicate that that value through
notifications to customers making sure
they know when we catch something bad
that we caught it
and you know ebr's quarterly strong
customer success team it's so it's a
it's an organizational effort to make
sure that we're not just bringing the
value but the customer understands
that value
as chief strategy and head of marketing
what does the day-to-day look like for
you so you have the company now you know
you raised i think almost 200 million
dollars 12 000 customers big company
what is the chief strategy job look like
these days you know are you looking for
you know the next you know and obviously
not looking for the next pivot
necessarily of the company but but you
you have to think of strategy
i'm fortunate because my day job is to
run marketing i check and i get to you
know play around in the strategy
uh playground along with my you know
fellow
uh
management you know it's a team effort
uh deciding on the company's strategy
and fate ultimately you know when i look
at what we're
uh
doing from a strategic lens you know i
have to first sort of
define what strategy is you know you ask
i mean you know you're you yourself
around stanford and you know that if
you'd ask a hundred professors at
stanford for their definition of
strategy you would get a hundred answers
my best attempt
is
more than maybe 200.
my best attempt at this is if i say
look in the business context at least
you should take a position
a clear position in the market and then
apply all your resources to achieve that
position so for me that's the question
of strategies what is the position
we want to take in the market and also
what is the market remember we're
building a new category go to market
security the idea that cyber security
would be sold to secure go-to-market
needs is novel it's a new category that
we are building and meeting and so not
only
did do you feel over time that there was
you know market education that needed to
happen and the things are that the way
that the market is evolving over time
that this education is becoming easier
and easier organically um
you know when like any time you start a
new category you know at the beginning
people are going to be looking at you
like i didn't know about this i didn't
know this was a problem i did not know
it affects me
i didn't know there were solutions for
this problem and you know we've we've
come a long way since then and i think
today
most
savvy go-to market teams understand at
least that there's a problem and in most
cases that they need a solution
and but the education process took time
and is ongoing and never ends
and the education i think that's a huge
part of it so but to educate you must
first define what are the boundaries
of the category what is go-to-market
security and i think that has been our
focus in saying what does it include
what it doesn't include and basically
we're saying all the means
digital means by which you go to market
i guess
are something that we want to protect if
you'd want an analogy for that maybe the
easiest way to think about it you think
about a company like salesforce okay i
always viewed salesforce they
characterized themselves as the customer
cloud right customer 360. but i always
looked at it as like the sales
enablement cloud really everything
or the go-to market i should say
enablement cloud everything you need to
go to market
we salesforce have in our cloud you need
crm we have that you need marketing
automation you need email engagement
you need bi tableau you need analytic
marketing analytics data-rama we have
that we enable your go-to-market motion
i say everything
salesforce enables we secure those are
the limits of the category um and we
keep it clean and human so i guess
that's how i was thinking about it
strategy
if you're looking internally how many
people are you there today we're
approximately 200 or nearing 200 people
and i think um there are plans to end
the year at around 320 people so it's a
hygro
operation
wow
okay okay got it and uh with 200 people
if i'm and if i'm looking now you know
on a leadership level it's 20 minutes
leaders after all um and i'm looking now
at you know looking at the executive
team and obviously you're presenting a
very very specific
you know
optimistic grand vision you know i'm
we're defining a new category we're
creating go to market security security
for go to market the intersection of
cyber security and marketing
if if you were to ask you know your
engineers your designers your product
managers
do they all understand you know the
magnitude of the of what it means to
create a new category that they're
effectively ambassadors of this notion
of what check is because i'm thinking
you know culturally how do you get an
organization to have like an army of
people saying we believe in this vision
we're not just engineers at this company
that has great yeah i think that's a
great how do you create that
the role of chief strategy officer as
you well know is not a standard
role in the season every company ceo and
a ceo and a
cfo
and a cmo but not necessarily a chief
strategy officer i i i think
the early on i said to myself and and a
guy you know our founder and ceo when we
were talking about this role we said
that is a big part of the role
is to not only have a strategy which is
something that i'm not responsible for
solely but is to make sure that strategy
um
is known throughout the organization
understood so that we're all working
towards the same north star you go
throughout 200 employees object from the
most senior executive to the most junior
intern and what you will find that they
all tell you oh yeah
we're the go-to market security company
we're on a mission to fight the fake web
i think everybody understands that from
developer to sales person to engineer
um and there's no other way to succeed i
think everyone has to be aligned uh
towards the same goal and and
it's a challenge it's internal
communication
it's
um
sales enablements but most importantly
it's having a clear
powerful but simple message that anyone
can understand like we're here to fight
the fake web
i love it and daniel i think that i
definitely learned a lot myself and
you know i'm always fascinated by these
exact stories you know especially when
it comes to creating a new category and
to finding the intersection between two
things that that that grew exponentially
parallel to each other and all of a
sudden they're beginning to intersect
and really we're talking about the last
few years i mean this is this is when
it's happening today everybody's doing
product-led growth everybody's doing you
know deep analytics into everything
that's happening in our in our softwares
especially when it comes to customer
acquisition i mean at the end this is
what companies you know this is what
they live on right and and these
instances of of fake and bots you know
like i mentioned before it's
one hand yes there's a monetary
substantial limitation there and things
in you know hindering that you have to
overcome but it's much more than that
you're shifting the whole understanding
of the organization and that's why i
think tech is so interesting because the
ripple effect of these bots and these
fake users and these fake leads
they grow in magnitude across the whole
the the across the whole pipeline of
what the organization is doing with
their leads and i think that's much more
important than just the money of the
cost of acquisition and daniel i really
appreciate your time and your your
effort and your energy and and spending
this time with me i appreciate it so
thank you very very much best of luck
with check and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you so much for having me
michael and take care
[Music]